- Hi, my name's Drew Hash.
We're here filming at my shop
in San Francisco.
Let's do a little tour.
I can show you
all the stuff
that I've built for it.
My very small two-car garage.
[upbeat music]
So this is my main
forging area.
At night, I'll pull my car in.
Everything that I have
is on wheels
so that it can be pushed
to the side.
I built pretty much everything
myself.
This is my big, 256 JHM
made-in-Texas anvil.
It's my baby.
This is my forge right here.
Forced air,
runs super, super hot.
- I'm John Stokes.
This is my shop.
Uh, this is where
the magic happens.
Piece-of-junk anvil.
It come from shopping online.
I got free shipping on it.
This is my piece-of-junk press.
I've bent the frame on it
twice now.
Bench grinder.
Just a regular bench grinder;
ain't nothing special about it.
Most of my tools
are pretty cheap.
Well, I've been running
this coal forge
for about five years now,
but I just got
this propane forge,
and one of my burners
don't work already.
And, uh, 900 pounds
of frickin' coal
before I decided to get
a propane forge.
- This is more my finish area
over here.
My lathe for turning
small parts.
And, uh, this is kind of
my clean bench.
It's pushed over here
in the corner.
I'll do all my handle
and woodwork over here.
This is my 24-ton
hydraulic press.
I use it a lot for Damascus.
Tool area.
This is my main grinder area.
I've got two 2x72 grinders.
Rockwell tester
and...drill press.
Assortment of hand tools.
This is my welding bench,
and this is where I do
a lot of work.
Everything I could possibly
need for knife-making in here.
- Most of what I do in here
is just very final
finish work.
Don't have the best tools
in the world.
I have a decent welder.
I have a really crappy
band saw.
This here's my belt sander.
It's, uh,
it's a piece of junk.
Uh, 4x36 sander.
Both of 'em.
It's got
a 4-horsepower motor.
And this one here
is older than I am.
It's still strong,
but aggravating.
Drill press.
Again, older than I am.
But it works better
than every tool in the shop,
including me.
Really, it's just,
I buy by deals.
Garage sales,
different stores
that sell cheap tools.
This one actually come from
my mother-in-law's father,
along with that belt sander.
I don't go spend full price
on a tool
because I--I don't have
the money to do so.
But this is what I do
every day.
I go to work,
and then I come home,
and I make knives,
and I use what I can.
Thank you for coming
and seeing my shop.
I'm hoping to make some killer
blades in here right shortly.
♪ ♪